Please welcome to the stage,
the death wish coffee company.
So,
uh,
there are a lot of you up here and I
know you guys all have very unique and
complicated catered roles inside the
company, so it would probably be best.
Why don't you guys just go down the line,
introduce yourself and let
people know what you do.
My name is Mike Brown.
I'm the owner of founders,
CEO and chief janitor at Deathwish coffee.
Uh, my name is Dustin
Alexander. I do a shipping,
I do inventory and I do purchasing.
I'm also part of the podcast with Jeff
to rally on the marketing manager at at
death wish.
Um, came Grogan and I run our
customer service department,
some of our events stuff and a
sales wholesale, stuff like that.
I'm Jeff airs,
I run our brand new broadcasting division
and I write and edit and produce our
weekly podcast fueled by death cast a,
my name is Alyssa hardy and I'm
the content manager at death wish.
So the reason why we brought
Deathwish here today,
and I think it's relevant
to a lot of Googlers, is um,
there's this great sort of just like
homecoming king esque type story of
starting out in a basement and just the
explosion of the past five years that
your company has gone through.
Why don't you recap, uh,
the history of the company for us?
Yeah.
So back in 2008,
I opened Saratoga coffee traders and
it was a small coffee shop in Saratoga
Springs,
New York.
And I learned pretty quickly that I didn't
know how to run a very good business
because I lost all my money. I lost
it all and all my went out the door.
But I was very, um, uh, I
didn't want to be a failure.
So I kept trying and trying and
trying and doing everything I could.
I actually hired my best friend,
Scott to come work with me for basically
free and we just struggled then every
single day we were in that shop trying
to figure out how to make it in a brick
and mortar business.
And then one day or like,
why don't we try to
sell our coffee online?
And that's why we developed a death
wish coffee. And it was, it was a,
a recommendation from our customers
because they would always come in and be
like, Hey, can I have, you know,
give me your strongest coffee.
And we'd go and be like, all right, do
they want the darkest coffee? Are they,
do they want the most caffeinated
coffee? And we're like, well,
wait a minute and let's just sit down
for a minute and figure this out.
Let's make a coffee that's not only dark,
not only tastes strong,
but also has the most caffeine. And, and
that's what we did. You know, we, we, we,
we developed this coffee by just blend.
Will we,
there are a lot of experimentation.
Well,
let's,
let's back up because I do think it's
important to qualify a death wish.
Coffee is known online as the
world's strongest coffee. Yes.
How do you qualify and quantify what
that means to be the world's strongest
coffee? Yeah. You know, I was
never focused caffeine at the
outset. It was always
about taste and flavor. Um,
caffeine informer and a few other
publications online, uh, uh,
deemed us the world's strongest
coffee with caffeine levels.
But I dunno, we personally, I
don't like to focus on that.
It just cause you can brew coffee stronger
by just adding more coffee and using
less water. Um, so to me it was all about
flavor and good flavor and, you know, the,
and everything that, you
know, when I, when I drink a
cup of coffee in the morning,
I want to wake up. Right.
You know, I want, I want to,
I want it to hit my like taste buds,
the chute open.
That's what I focused on
that, that experience. Um,
but going back to your question,
like I said,
I don't like to focus on the caffeine,
but caffeine does have
something to do with it. And we,
because we use reboost to beans.
Uh,
reboost beans have between
two and three times the, the,
the typical caffeine content
of Arabica beans. Um,
we do naturally get more
caffeine in our club.
Yeah. And that's a big part
of it, right? Because it,
one would think that it would
be easy to make a, you know,
a new world's strongest coffee.
You just go make a coffee and then find
a bunch of caffeine and caffeine. Yeah.
So,
but that's not really what's going on
you guys or have brewed this batch of
beans and roasted in such a way,
uh,
to just naturally get this effect without
having to force it. Yup. It's organic.
It's fair trade.
There's no additives.
We don't add any caffeine to it or
it's just pure coffee and that's,
you know, we're purists,
believe it or not. And we love,
we love just straight black
drip coffee. Sure. So,
so you find this niche and
you say, okay, I can start,
people are demanding a certain thing for
me. The strongest coffee, high caffeine,
but also really bold flavor.
Uh,
we got that and we want to
get it out to the people.
So you left brick and mortar behind and
just said, we can do this via the web?
Yeah, pretty much. I mean, it's
still in my coffee shop right now.
It's doing better, thank
God. But yes, we, we,
we took staff of the online market
cause my customer like, hey,
why don't you try selling this online?
And I was like, all right, I'll try.
And you know,
I sold the bag via Google ads.
I was how I sold my
first bag and they said,
and I got my first good review. And the
guy was like, I still remember his name,
Phil Bron. Um, how to Oakland.
I filled in horrible. Yeah,
I felt okay the first bag.
And he gave me a good review. It's like
this is some strong coffee and it's the,
or some of the best coffee ever had.
And from the air,
like that review lead it up to
another sale and another sale.
So I was selling basically one pound a
week and then two pounds a week and three
pounds a week.
And all of a sudden it just snowballed
into this company where it was me at
first me and, uh, one of my experts
does Megan. And then one day,
good morning America, give me
a call and they're like, hey,
we've heard about your coffee online,
we want to open the show with it tomorrow.
Can we come up and interview
interview you? And I was like,
at that moment, ponder that you'd
think. I would say yes immediately,
but I don't know there's
that, it was a, I don't know.
For me it was a great step because I,
I knew I wanted it,
but I didn't know if I was
ready, but I was just like, yes.
And they came that day. I'm
like, when are you going to come?
I was thinking like a week or two. They're
like, we'll be there in three hours.
So they good morning America show up at
my store and three hours I closed the
store,
I cleaned it up and they interviewed
me and the next morning they open.
Good Morning America drinking death,
wish coffee in our mugs.
And Sam champion was a
weatherman at the time and he,
he was our coffee expert and he said,
this is some great coffee.
And then from there orders took off. Like,
I didn't have enough coffee,
enough bags, enough people. Um,
and that's how basically
higher and everyone,
it's just because it was just me at
the time and I was like, oh my God,
I have all these orders I have to fulfill.
Where am I going to find people to
help me do this? So I went to my co,
my customers and my coffee shop
and I literally asked my customers,
can you help me fulfill these orders? And
that's, and that's where like everyone,
that's where it started and that's
where I found like the greatest people,
which brings us to a lot of you guys.
And the,
the interesting thing I find about that
is it's like you said, you, you pick
bull that you knew or people
who are customers are yours.
You guys are not necessarily
Barista coffee. Hey, related. Yeah.
Yeah. I knew nothing about
marketing though. I mean,
I know a little bit about coffee, but, so
how was the, we're skipping a few major,
major points. What are the major? So
one of the things that, um, Mike, uh,
as admitted in that, that, you know,
rags to riches story is that, uh,
he was looking for a way to supplement
some income because the, um,
the coffee shop was failing and you know,
he found a product that
worked out and they,
him and Megan would just reach out
to massive amounts of just an email.
It's like cold emails, like, Hey,
we have the world traumas, coffee.
That's how good morning America found it.
It was literally in a basement and
they were just sending emails and like,
we have this thing and it got mentioned
in a few other publications first.
And then when good morning America came,
um,
it was way worse than, than what Mike
just said when all those orders came in.
And,
and I came on at that point,
I'm taking him on a little bit
after that are a good friend,
Eric Donovan was there who,
you know, personally. Um,
and there was thousands
and thousands of orders.
And I remember just seeing it there were
in this basement where the floor is not
really finished and it's like shorter
than I am tall and it was just piles and
piles of orders and we were like
stickering back's feeling coffee,
like weighing it out one bag at
a time. And it was insane. Um,
we got kicked off of Amazon,
we got a lifetime ban off of Ebay
because people thought we were scams. Um,
that was interesting.
So it took us what was scammy,
they didn't get their back like
on our website at the time,
which if you could go back there is,
I'm sure you guys know there's you,
there's an archive.org or whatever it is,
where you can see what the Google
way back machine way back machine.
I wouldn't have bought it.
So that's on them cause they
bought it off that website.
Slash slash I was a web
developer of that website.
It converted like crazy.
First of all,
the conversion rate on there
is better than it is now.
You'll get it in five days and it's
like three, four weeks. And, and, uh,
we thought it was a dead company.
I didn't get hired for three.
I kept coming back every
day for three months.
I didn't get actually get hired because
we didn't think it was going to be
company after that. Like, well,
we just watched the ship sink and a let's
play the titanic song as we go down.
And, uh, it wasn't that, you know, we,
we, uh, through customer service, uh,
and just apologizing to everybody and
saying, you're going to get it. Um,
people kept ordering.
And then we spent the next year and a
half trying to build a foundation, um,
to the company. Uh, we
moved into a warehouse.
We begged and begged and begged
Amazon and Ebay to let us back on, um,
and called me in Amazon. And
I think in on Google too. And,
and the Internet for a lot of times,
we're the number one coffee and sometimes
the number one grocery products,
Amazon. So that was just an, a, an a test,
a testament to Mike and
him just being like,
we're going to do this the right way.
We're not going to screw people over.
We're not going to, you know, fold.
We're just going to give
everybody what we promised and uh,
and we were able to deliver and it was
a pretty amazing time for the company.
One of the common threads of
the story, uh, seems to be this,
this foundation based around
communication. You guys are very,
very communicative to, like you
said, people were placing an order,
expecting it in five days.
You're then reaching out to them three
weeks later and communicating the delays.
Um, but this is not uncommon. Like
you guys embraced the online space.
You guys embraced so much social media.
Talk about why going that route.
Like it, you could easily have taken out
a loan and spent $100,000 on a marketing
campaign, but going this route, it seems
to have been very effective for you. Yeah.
Our number one value is customer status.
And we,
we,
I give everyone absolute freedom to
go above and beyond to make sure our
customers are satisfied and happy. And,
and I, I know people say that a lot,
especially businesses, but our number
two value is profitability. And it's all,
it's, it's a ranking system. So we will,
because customer satisfaction
is our number one value.
And then to be profitable is, uh,
you know, it's two or three or four,
I can't remember exactly,
but we will take losses to
make our customers happy.
So we'll go above and beyond to do that.
One story I'm thinking of it just
pops into my head, uh, is one,
one day a customer called,
and he was very upset with our cake gumps
because we had the new k cups and Kira
came out with a new brewer,
the Keurig 2.0 and the guy's like,
you know, I bought your cops,
they don't work in my new machine.
And he's like,
he was very upset and I'm like, you don't
mess with people's coffee. Yeah, exactly.
So I was like, oh, I'm like, how
am I going to fix this problem?
So I talked to the customer
service and they were like, oh,
we can send them another bag.
And I'm like, no, you know,
let's just send them a new,
like a better brewer.
So we went and we found that the
top rated a single serve brewer.
And we sent this guy like a brand
new brewer. And it wasn't that,
it wasn't a cure. Grand was, it was, I
think it was the ox box and you know,
it was just the top
rated brewer at the time.
And we sent that to them and I've never,
and that guy,
he turned out to be a CEO of like
some like big construction company.
And he was floored. He
like, you guys are amazing.
And to me that's going to say,
I don't know,
that means a lot about my customer
service team that they would think of it
think to do that. And that's what we're
all about, just making people's day,
like being able to provide
that type of values.
Who are our customers where
it's not just, um, you know,
here's another bag of cups,
you know, good luck. You know,
we want to really
embrace customer service.
Well,
it seems to go more than just embracing
good customer service because you've
expanded out into social
media in unique ways. Uh,
that again foster communication
and sort of community, uh,
which is interesting for a consumable
product company, I think. And,
and that sort of leaves us, leads us
into the conversation about the podcast.
So as part of all the social media growth,
you guys have created your own
identity and branded a podcast.
Yeah, I mean it, Dustin could talk
a little bit more about that. I bet.
But I mean to me like it just seemed
like we want to fuel people's passion.
That's our,
that's our motto.
And to do that I feel like we have to be
in contact with them on a regular basis
and, and, and sometimes people
are only buying coffee, you
know, once a month. So we,
you know, we were thinking how, how can
we be a part of these people's lives, uh,
on an ongoing basis?
And that's where the podcast came in.
Yeah. When, um, when Michael first
brought it up, it was, to me,
it was a way to give a
voice for the company. Um,
not only with our employees,
so we do employee interviews,
but also with all the
influencers that we work with.
Because we worked with a
lot of influencers that now
have a voice through the
company with the podcast.
But on top of that, you know,
it gives a little bit more
for the customer to be a
part of the company and also
keep really well informed with the
company. There's a clear style,
um,
to the identity of the company.
I mean obviously it's a bold step
to call yourself Deathwish coffee.
Why would you want to actively drink
something that is threatening your life?
But that sort of fear behind
that. I do. Absolutely.
Um,
so the whole thought of the name
and the image of the coffee is,
I was,
you know,
when it's coming up
with death wish coffee,
I was sitting there was that night,
so imagine me sitting in a room at night,
it's dark out have is this computer screen
in front of me and I was in my second
floor apartment and pour as
broke as a joke. Like I hadn't,
it's so boring. And I'm
like, I'm like, how, what,
what am I, what? I had this
product in mind and like,
how do I put this on a screen?
And I looked down at this can I was,
I was drinking a four Loko at the time.
All right.
That works for local at the time.
And I'm like, who is he? I had on it,
had a picture of is a mean dog.
And my girlfriend and bought me this
Cousy when she went away on vacation and I
said Deathwish under it. And I'm like,
ah, I mean that's, that's a cool,
that's a pretty cool like name I could,
I could,
I could go with that for a name of this
coffee. And I'm like, how am I going to,
what would I want to see if I walked
into somebody's kitchen? Like,
if I saw bad coffee, what would I pick
up and look at it and be intrigued by,
and I had this image of a poisoned, like
a poisoned bottle, like an old school,
like poison via, like we'd pick
up and be like, what is like,
what kind of coffee are you drinking
with this poisoned label on it? Uh,
and that was the whole concept behind it.
And I was like,
Deathwish poisoned while this could, this
could work. So, you know, I did some,
like I wanted to Photoshop and
like Photoshop some stuff around.
And so like I got the preliminary
logo. It's not the logo. It is now. Um,
I'm putting in my risk is actually
have the logo on my wrists,
which it's just not a temporary tents.
There are tattoos but um,
tattoos of it. Yes, that poisoned logo.
That's the whole image I had in mind
in my brain at the time. And it,
well, it's fed so much into the
larger identity at this point.
You guys with the podcasts
of really embracing this,
and I know you're a big into MMA and
you guys have some influencers from that
space that in rock and roll and yeah,
I mean that whole area of Edgy
influencers has just opened up to us.
It becomes like a lifestyle brand.
And a certain point pretty early on,
it became a lifestyle brand. We realized,
and I don't think it was the intent,
if you look at some of our original ads,
it was Leno,
a lawyer who can't wake up in the morning.
So he like drinks the coffee.
But we found out that our number one
people that were spreading the word,
we're either like, you know,
musicians are recovered,
addicts who wanted something to kind of
sink your teeth into and a brand that
really spoke to them. And, and
so many people drink coffee.
It's a number two commodity
in the world behind oil. Um,
and we had the igs most badass brand and
when we started this thing, there was,
when Mike started, there wasn't a world
tour on this coffee. Now you can Google.
It's weird up here.
Say that.
Yeah, you can search on the
Internet. You, it's kind of cool,
but you can and you see so many different
people claiming to have that claim and
they have our, you know, uh,
one of my favorite stories is we see so
many websites that try to like knock us
off.
And there was one that used our exact
html html code and didn't take the bottom
off. So it said, why try
Deathwish click here and our,
and it was, it was also effectively
signing people up for your email.
And actually we collected email
address postures. Once they failed,
they had their, our bag with their
logo photoshops and top of it.
And we would email them and
be like, that's our bag. And
they're like, no, it's not.
It's like, it has our address on
it, on the side of it, the bag.
And that you still couldn't hear your
website? We have Photoshop. Yeah, it was,
it was ridiculous. But, um,
it speaking to it being a lifestyle brand,
I mean there are people who walk our
shirts and our hats and everything like
that without actually even
trying the coffee. So, and
get tattoos and get tattoos.
Um, people who've, they've probably
tried the coffee at that point though.
That's okay.
I'd hope so. You've mentioned tattoo
seventh, sorry to cut that off. Were you?
Oh, I mean, yeah. So we have a few of
our biggest fans definitely have, um,
our logo tattooed on them, which is
insane. People crying all the time.
They say, Hey, we want to get
your logo tattooed. Is that okay?
Well that's a big commitment,
you know, we're never like,
oh just go ahead and do it. It's kind
of like pretty sure you want to do this.
You know, we do try and kind of talk
them down, but it is pretty cool.
You guys just finished the New York
City Tattoo? Yes. Yeah. Did anybody,
did you watch anybody get a death? Which
Tattoo? No. No actually we weren't going.
I mean, I mean it's, it's
tough. It's a weird term just to
temporary. Yeah. I always, we always
joke after they get it. Like, Oh,
let's talk about actually selling our
name. We're going to be something else.
When I was in Santa,
very early became a lifestyle brand and
one of our first marketing campaigns, um,
was, you know, what fuels you,
you are a field by death. Um,
and that kind of to kind of skip
forward back to the podcast, which,
which started a few months ago.
And Jeff is also the cost to that.
And he kind of headed that whole project.
Um,
we found out very early on that it
wasn't just, you know, musicians and,
and all these people, it was a engineers.
It was, you know, comic book artists,
nurses, you know, passionate people
about what they do for a living room.
And there are Olympians
fueled by death isn't just an idea of,
you know,
what is your coffee and coffee I like,
we keep saying as a lifestyle,
but fueled by death is every
single one of us in this room,
every single one of us outside of this
room on this planet wants to do something
significant before we leave this planet
for good. Because death is inevitable.
Whether you get hit by a bus in five
minutes or you live to be 90 years old.
And what's interesting is,
is that everybody in the world
enjoys figuring that out.
Whether it's or hard,
you know,
journey to get there or it's something
that you know you're passionate about and
it's very interesting to
attack a conversation that
way. And that's where the,
the idea of this podcast
Kinda came back about.
And it's interesting to be able to bring
it to a business and because we're not
sitting there and being like,
well,
what kind of coffee do you like and
why does that fuel you real quick?
What that would get boring. It would
get incredibly boring. But I mean,
like we've talked to, you know,
astronauts and rock stars and,
and normal people and like, why are you,
what gets you out of bed in the morning?
Why do you get out of bed in the morning
and what gets you out of bed the next
morning? Why? Why are you doing it? Not
the coffee. There's, there's something,
there's something that you're passionate
about. And that conversation is always,
will never not be interesting.
You know? And that's,
and that's kind of what we are all
about as a lifestyle brand too.
Because what's fun about a coffee
company is coffee is a lifestyle.
I all of you out there probably have
you own way that you drink coffee and it
becomes your morning ritual,
whether it's just putting it in a drip
machine and hitting the brew button or
we're going to a gas station or
ruined and you know, taking out your,
your chemistry set and really
making that perfect cup of coffee,
like whatever it is that is your path,
that your passion for your
coffee at that moment.
But after you drink your coffee,
then your day starts, you know,
and then what are you doing with your day?
And we want to be a part of your day,
not just in that, in that
beginning of it, you know,
it's a, it's a, it's a great
narrative to hear about the passion,
the seeking passion in,
in the people who are around
you in a part of that lifestyle.
And then equating that back to what you
went through to actually get this thing
up off the ground. Uh,
looking back at it now,
were there times when you thought,
you know what, this isn't worth it,
or were there times that you had to
like refine that passion and yourself of
like,
we can make this work?
I do want to do it even though it's
early on with the, with the coffee shop,
I believe when I started death,
wish I was probably only probably one
or two months from closing the doors
because it was, it was, I just didn't
have any money left and I ate them.
I had my car repoed and how to
sell my house I was living with,
I had to move back into,
my mom has lived in behind the garage,
so I was very close to calling
it quits and just, you know,
but I am super, I try to be like,
I didn't want to be a failure,
you know what I mean? That
to me, like that word.
And it's funny I think back and people,
my friends and family, Hey Mike,
how's things over to the coffee shop? And
every time like, oh, they're going great.
Thanks for asking. But deep inside I was
just like, I'm crashing and burning here.
Oh No. So yeah.
So after that I'm they know, I'm like,
oh, I gotta try something. So yeah,
the online, once the online sales
started to pick up, I'm like holy crap.
Like maybe I can keep this thing open
a little bit longer. And I'm like,
if I had just made like
5,000 bucks a year,
that's pretty much all I
need to like make things.
If I had worked a little longer. So yeah,
there was that time where it's almost,
I was at the absolute, you know, ready
to ready to call it quits. But yeah,
we hung on night.
I kept going with it and then I was just,
am I gonna pay my bills back someday?
I guess, you know? And I did. So
you want to speak about
something specific, which is,
I would like for you guys to talk about
the super bowl ad and how that came to
pass because I think it's a testament to
your activity on social media space and,
and how hard you guys work
to build that community.
And then not actually that community
paying you back. Interesting.
We the greatest fans,
community customers in the world,
hands down like date.
When we keep going back to lifestyle,
we keep talking about that they
made it a lifestyle. You know,
they made this brand what it is,
they're the reason why we,
we got the Superbowl commercial in the
first place because it was a, it was,
it's a, uh, small business, big game.
So basically intuit quickbooks put out
a contest for a small business with less
than I think 50 employees and about
15,000 businesses actually entered them.
They were one of them. Um, and
it was a vote based contest.
So basically you would ask your
community to vote for you, click,
click a very simple link.
Um,
and essentially the contest
was very simple. Uh,
the person with the most votes would win.
Um,
so it ended up being narrowed down
to I think a few hundred and then,
and then 10. And that was insane.
I mean, at 15,000, we had no idea.
But coming back to the, the failure
of conversation that you're having.
I think that was the first time where
we kind of said if if we don't win this,
that would suck.
Like it felt like it would be a setback
and it was almost are put so much work
into it. So much work into it. It felt
like it would be the end of the world.
And I think that is one of the
reasons why we ended up winning,
cause we put 100% of our focus on
winning the competition. It sounds silly,
but it really brought our art team
together like that one driving purpose and
everyday we'd start, it would be big.
How are we going to get more votes today?
Yup.
And it came down to us and Chubbies and
[inaudible] is a five and dime out of
Buffalo, New York. Great small little
store. They had all of Buffalo,
all 6 million people in buffalo
behind him voting every day. Yeah.
And they were a brick and
mortar shop that would sell.
So find a tiny figurines
and Chinese you want to win.
They were like, we don't want, what
do we do if we went and,
and intuit did tell us after,
I don't know if I should say this, but
they were like, if someone like that one,
we would ever do this kindness again
because there's no way to quantify that or
help that out. But, um, it
was, it was insane. You know,
the first three months it was six months
competition and the first three months
where it started with 15,000 and I
honestly didn't think you have a chance.
We were seven employees at the
time. We're going again, some,
some juggernauts of companies.
I mean, for instance,
Chubbies shorts while they have a little
less than 50 employees stay at 125
college brand ambassadors spreading
the word, which aren't on the books,
which I think that's cheating. That's just
my opinion. A victim. Um, but one that,
those guys are good guys. They're
cool. They're cool. Um, but when,
when they said we want the top 10, it
became very real. Um, and then it's like,
okay, we did a lot of work.
I'm going to this point.
But we were kind of like still doing
our day to day stuff once they're like,
you guys are one of 10. And
they basically picked, you know,
you had to have a
community of people voting,
but they also picked really good stories.
Like one,
some of the people we are going
against in the top 10 were like, uh,
this Harvard business person,
uh, this, this awesome,
awesome chick was trying
to solve world hunger by a,
you put your fruit and whatever on
this paper. And it would, it would, uh,
make it last longer. And it's like,
we're just sell coffee. We're going,
it's amazing,
amazing stories and amazing companies.
And all 10 of them were
very incredible stories.
So when we actually want it,
um, we, you know, it was,
it was the first time we came
together as a team and it really,
team is the most important thing that you
can really do anything you want to do.
You just have to meet him.
Everyone bought in.
And that I think we realize that we
can accomplish pretty much anything if,
if we,
I mean it sounds so cliche,
but if you put your mind to it and every
day I'm like, it would be like, you know,
what is, what $7 million worth of
heat, what would you do for $7 million?
Cause that's essentially
what you're getting.
You're getting a $7 million commercial.
When we were going to
be set as a business,
if we could just figure out
how to win this thing. And uh,
it was a lot of pressure and there were
months where we didn't have a day off.
We're already going to every event like,
um, me and Mike would go to a literal,
you know, football game and
just hand out things like, yeah,
we're a coffee company.
Both here's, and in Buffalo.
And we didn't realize we were going
against those guys. But Tana is tailored,
had our march, she is the head of
our marketing. So she had, okay,
let's try this today. Let's try
this today. We're, we're not there,
we're not winning.
And it was insane.
I would say that if we didn't establish
customer service as our number one value
way before this competition,
I don't think we would have won because
it wouldn't have resonated with our fans
are with our community
at all. Um, and they,
we have made it a point to involve
them with the company the entire time.
So I think that kind of
set us up. Um, you know,
our fans would when contact us and say,
Hey, wait, I said a calendar invite on my,
on my calendar so that I remember to
vote for every day, every single day. Um,
I created a separate mailing list,
um, opt in for people. You know,
we would send one a day and almost
no one on subscribe from that list,
which is insane. And the open rates and
the click rates were incredible. Um,
so our community, um, and just placing,
placing them on top of our values,
I think is the most important
thing that we ever did.
We never knew it would have actually come
back to us. And it's such a great way
being real and genuine also. And
one of the things that, you know,
Mike and Tana found out early on where
they want people want it to see, you know,
your faces they have, you're now
their favorite coffee brand. Um,
and they, we made, you know,
our brand very relatable like none of
us have experienced in any of the things
we have jobs and now, you know, um,
most of us didn't graduate from college.
We basically googled business.
Thanks guys. Yeah, no,
but seriously it was literally
like we had a Google education.
I know you guys probably heard that and
it might be one of those weird trigger
things like Ugh,
but we did do one social media,
how do you want an ad campaign and how do
you deal do it today. We still do that.
And because of that we
were able to kind of like,
we didn't have a whole 20 years of, of
experience and like this is the way it is,
where we're going to go.
A lot of those dinosaurs fall
at the times we are at the time.
It's like we literally grew
up in this age, in this era,
and we figured out how to do
everything by just searching it online.
And it's an a test like a testament
to the power of what you guys do,
which is incredible.
And
uh, that's kind of where we are,
why we are where we are today.
And it is a story of a very meteoric rise,
a very short time period to go from
the brick and mortar basement roasting.
You know, coming up with the
recipe to where you are now,
where it's the line is diversified.
Like you said,
you're making everything from whole being
to like k cups that people come by and
just pop in a machine.
I want to have you guys
speak to somewhere out there,
maybe here it's a Googler or maybe it's
somebody who's watching the video at
home that has their thing,
their passion, and they want it,
they want a similar kind of experience.
What would you tell them?
How would you advise them to,
to get involved in that too?
Maybe not mimic what you guys have
done but at least be on that path.
Yeah,
I mean just go for it.
And when you feel like you're getting
uncomfortable and just push a little
further because I feel like,
you know,
thinking back that point in my life,
I almost quit.
I was that close to success.
You know what I mean?
I was that close and I did
just push a little bit further.
So whenever you're doing or if
you have a passion, go for it.
And right when you get to that point
we were about to quit is it'd be like,
actually no, I'm going to push
myself, you know, two for there.
And I think that if everyone did that,
which is a little bit more persistent,
like the things you can
accomplish are amazing.
Do you guys agree?
I mean the podcast creators who are here,
you guys just started doing it,
right? Yeah. I ain't know where.
And you guys have now grown
to a fairly decent presence,
GL and baby cas, just 30 episodes
out right now. But I mean, yeah,
it's one thing I say about this company
and this really works towards any kind
of anything, anything you're
passionate about is that, you know,
this company Deathwish coffee is,
I always equate it to a living,
breathing organism.
It's something that learns every day.
It's not just coffee, it's
not just the brand. It's,
it's what we're trying to achieve,
what we're trying to do and anything,
whether it's the video game you like or,
or you know,
the hobby that you're creating.
You know,
when your workshop at home or the job
that you have to go to day in and day out,
there's always another journey.
There's always another path you
can take to get to the goal.
The goal is just there,
but that's never the finish line.
There's never a finish line. And we talk
about that a lot on the podcast. In fact,
one of the influencers of the company
said it the best and we quote him probably
every single time. It doesn't knows who
I'm going to say. Yeah, you did. Yeah.
Naked and afraid. Um, he said it the best.
You said you either win or you learn.
There is no losing, there's
never losing. And, and there's,
and when you win there's more
to go. You know, and that's,
that's a testament to what we do.
But it's a testament to what you all do,
what anybody can do. And I think
that's, I think that's powerful.
And just to speak on what,
what Michael brought up,
Jeff and I were podcasting
before we started
podcasting for the company.
We had our own little mini podcast,
but we were kind of hitting the end
of the road there where it was like,
is this done?
Are we done with this?
And we decided we were
going to hang on to it.
And then that's when Mike was like, well,
why don't you do it for the company?
And it was like, yeah, let's do it. Let's
get it together. Now we have a vision. We,
you know, we have a focus
and we now, it's been great.
It's been amazing. It's been an amazing
trip and it's been very short so far
and we're not even, we're not
even started, you know, I mean,
we started out doing the idea of the,
hey,
let's have a weekly podcast where
people can learn about the company,
but we can also, you know, ask
those questions to influencers and,
and interesting people
and the employees as well.
But now we're adding video
and we're adding live video.
We're doing Facebook lives and we're
doing, um, as we do it and live,
I'm learning how to do TV
tricks as we're going live.
So I'm on camera talking to you and also
putting camera two on as it's happening
with other graphics and I'm failing,
but I'm doing better at it.
Yeah.
So I mean like there's always new ideas.
There's always new ways to like not
even just, it's not improving something,
it's just going farther, going that
extra step, you know, like it's,
it's awesome and it's always going to be
tough when you're breaking ground. I
mean, we're doing things that no other co,
especially coffee companies are doing.
No other coffee companies are making a
podcast like we're doing it or you know,
making comic books like we do.
Um, but when you break ground,
nobody's been there before. You
can't just Google it, you know,
how do I start a podcast and make
it a live show on Facebook live?
You're not going to get an answer.
So it's,
it's just a nature of the
beast of breaking ground.
You're going to have to figure out
stuff that nobody's figured out yet,
but that's where the success comes from.
Gone back to Mike's Story. I think
this is really important. Um,
like mentioned pushing past your,
um,
uncomfortable point. I'm making a
list of your worst case scenario.
I know that's what Mike definitely did
and I'm weighing whether or not those
things are worse than
failing business wise. Um,
I know Mike made a list of best and worst
case scenario and all of them ended up
happening, um, mom's place,
et Cetera, et cetera.
Um, but you do kind of have to
push past that a little bit.
So I do think going back
to your original question,
make a list of the worst things
that could possibly happen.
And if you're okay with those things
happening at the expense of creating an
amazing business and just, just
try it out, we'll definitely work.
But at least you'll know, you'll
know what's to come. I mean,
worst case scenario is not doing
it at all. Right. That's true.
Part of the, uh, what we
kind of omitted from this,
this kind of rags to riches
story is Mike had a career.
He had his masters in accounting.
He wasn't accounted for.
The state worked for the state had seen
all these people that do this thing
where they show up everyday to
work and they're just like, yeah,
no one's really happy. No one's,
there's nothing really driving them.
They're just like kind
of, you know, or robotic.
They just get up and they
drink their coffee. Uh,
and then they go to work
and they do their thing.
They go home and they go to bed and
he's like, you know, I hate this.
I want to do something I like.
And I liked being in coffee shops.
I don't know much about coffee, but I
can figure it out. And then, you know,
a lot of us were at crossroads in life
and we kind of joined the team and I
would say that the most important
thing is just never settling. Um,
I know that like, so he, he had a career,
he didn't like it and just try something
else. And it took him, you know,
took five or six years
before everyone told him.
It was like the worst thing were sitting.
He was gonna make. Um, I personally,
and I dropped out of community
college three times. I was a banker.
I had the whole career in banking when I
was in my early twenties. I hated it. Um,
I quit my, uh, family and friends
saw me. It was the worst decision.
I moved back to upstate New York and I
ended up basically homeless for a while.
His couch couch. I would be spent a lot
of time with Matt and his beautiful wife.
And it was, it was a very, very dark time,
but I found Deathwish and
it's just seizing opportunity.
And now tell has got similar stories
unless I worked for a teen vogue I think
for a little while she still
does and we've all done things.
Who for a kitchen you worked for
a kitchen. Like it was, you know,
a lot of different times where we just
weren't happy with our current situation
and a lot of people settle.
And I think that's the biggest mistake
you can make it just dealing with it
because you think that's all you got and
just looking for opportunities and and
uh, and when they're there,
you know, doors will open.
You just have to know
to walk through them.
Hmm. Very good. Very good.
I do want to leave plenty of time for
you guys to ask questions as well.
There are microphones in the
aisles so I encourage you to,
to make your way to the microphone.
So with your questions prepared
while people are getting ready,
I want you guys to go down the line.
I don't want you to tell me
how you take your coffee.
Yes. I take my coffee out of a
Chemex, typically black, no sugar,
no cream,
strong as you can make it,
but I only drink it in the morning.
I get a little weirder with it.
I uh, I make something called death
proof coffee, which is mixed with butter,
MCT oil, blended. Um, I stick
a few other things in there.
Um, but yeah, that's, that's my
morning ritual. One Cup in the morning.
I'm good to go all day.
Typically.
I mean actually came in as like a coffee
connoisseur and it was such a brat.
I still loved the third wave coffee,
but um, typically black, but you'll,
you'll catch me going to the Keurig
a lot more than it. So here I am.
I have, uh, two different, uh,
kinds where it's like I have my hangover
on Sunday where just like really just
terrible diner coffee with a
bunch of cream and sugar. Um,
I've also figured out through this job,
I didn't know much about coffee. We see,
use it as a literal,
a utility to get you through your day.
A lot of people will drink an
energy drink or something like that.
And they would always be like,
dude,
there's more caffeine in coffee than
there is in that. You don't need that.
It's terrible for you. Um, so I usually
have three cups, uh, between eight and 11.
Um, and it, it'll me to where the
till about three where I started that,
that a crash and then I'll have one more
cup cause I allows me to go home and
get stuff done afterward.
So I used to be cream and sugar all
the time and then I got really lazy in
college.
So it's black and it's a lot.
I drink probably five or six cups a day.
My desk is directly next to all of our
coffee machines and I'm bouncing off the
walls by five and he never shuts up.
He never shuts up.
And he started having panic attacks.
So he's had a contact person,
that dino video where it's like a
fresh pot. It's like his wife was like,
are you all right?
And what happened?
We know that it has an occupational
hazard when you work with top.
Yeah. It's just, it's just how it works,
especially when you don't pay for it.
Where we work and we have really strong
coffee. And then we started snakes.
And one of the things I do want to
say real quick is we always look for
alternative methods.
And we just released a nitro cold brew,
which is very concentrated
Deathwish coffee.
And Jeff would mean that home and
have a panic attack and not know why.
And it's because he would
have one of those too late
in the afternoon. Something.
Yeah.
How about you?
Um, I wake up very, very early,
so I start with a chemics and I put a
little bit of almond milk in it and then I
get to work and I make one the second I
get to work in a French press typically.
Yeah.
I feel like we haven't heard a
lot about the coffee itself. Yeah.
So I'm very curious about things like
sourcing, roasting, how you blend it,
where are you? Uh, and also
like, I guess most importantly,
it gets very unusual to have a good,
like higher end coffee be me at,
I've ever Boosta. And what it's like,
you know, using Matt rather than Arabica,
which every other single
copy I'm more of uses,
we'll use a rabbit goes well. Okay. Um,
I think our, I think Mike's Mike. Yeah.
I mean,
our roasters is not here today.
That's probably why we haven't talked
about it, but he told you we'd have it.
It's in a, it's an Indian
Peruvian blend. Um,
so we get the reboost it means from India.
They're organic and fair trade.
We're actually one of the few companies
out there that, that have, uh, an or,
or an organic source for reboost the
emotional boost. Do you find? Um,
it doesn't have the, uh, the
Usda organic certification on it,
but we have a very good, uh, supplier.
We work with importers and actually
in New York here and New Jersey, um,
and on the west coast, and they're
able to source that for us. Um,
the Peruvian is also organic fair trade.
Our coffee is a blended post rose,
so we don't blend the beans and then
roast them. We roast them separately.
So you'll see if you
actually opened a bag,
you'll see two different shades in
there because we found that if you,
if you blended post roast, um, the flavor,
you'll get a more a fuller flavor.
Uh,
we use Loring roasters.
It's almost like a giant popcorn
popper. I like to say, ah,
there's no direct flame on the beans ever.
So there's no scorching.
If you crack or beans open, they're
roasted a uniformly straight through.
Um,
it's the most efficient roaster on the
market right now because it circulates
the hot air.
So we don't waste a lot of gas and
there's an not a lot of exhaust either.
It also make,
it also provides the benefit of us
not having to have an afterburner,
which a lot of companies will have,
which will reduce the
environmental impact.
So it's the most environmental
friendly roaster. We have two of those.
We have a 35 kilos in a
70 kilo, uh, at this time.
I want to speak a little bit on specialty
coffee and reboost a little bit.
Definitely when we first entered the
coffee industry reboost it was not
highly regarded. I wouldn't say
it's highly regarded, but um,
there are the NCAA, which is the
specialty Coffee Association of America.
They actually have set up something at
all of their events to compete with rebel
or booster. And, um,
that's something that I'm actually
really proud of at this point.
It's cool you get to taste
for boost against each other.
So even though it's not necessarily like
the third wave kind of light roast, um,
uh, choice, I, it definitely is.
It's own beast that people do love and
enjoy and I think it's a 60% of coffee
enjoyed is a lot of the
times mixed with our booster
right now. Yeah. Be especially
because there's been a,
there's been a problem with coffee rust.
Um,
and because of this,
um,
the coffee industry is starting to
make hybrid plants with Arabica.
Andrea boost it because there will
boost is much more, uh, hardy.
It can defend against this coffee rust
that they were initially thinking it was
going to,
we don't really raise coffee prices,
but because they were able to
blend the two plants together,
um, it's resistant. So actually a lot of
coffee, you're probably getting all that.
He thinks Arabica has some
has some are booster in it.
There's actually was studies that were
just done where a scientist just crack
the genome on reboost a coffee and Arabica
has been out there for about a year
and so both genomes are now completely
mappable and that's why we're getting a
lot of these hybrid plants,
which is very interesting because now
we're going to be able to get a new type
of being, you know,
that he has never even,
the world's never seen and the
possibilities of coffee are endless again.
So it's,
it's pretty exciting.
I think a lot of people just, you're here
like Oh, single origin Arabica beans.
And you just hear that from different
people and you think like, oh yeah,
that's the best one. Right? Like that's
what I thought. I was like, yeah,
this is the best. I didn't know. You
just don't know until you try it.
So I'll be able to just,
the blind taste tests are very funny and
especially, I mean, coming from me, I was,
I would criticize everyone's way of
brewing coffee and I was, you know,
I was that person kind of until someone
stuck a blind taste test in front of me
and then who was a jerk.
All personal preference,
personal preference. I tell
people that all the time.
We try to kind of, we're like
the gateway coffee drug. Um,
and I think having someone like Taya
and you know that that has really been
around coffee for a long time,
people will buy it because it is,
it has a gimmicky approach, right?
It's a, it's colon, world's tronics
coffee. People were like,
screw that. That's stupid.
The third wave coffee people really
didn't respect that. Um, but the,
the modern person and, and most people
don't have that, uh, you know, pallet yet.
They don't know what good coffee is. So
we have this thing where it's, you know,
Mike worked at a coffee shop. He was able
to test every kind of coffee he wanted,
shrunk coffee, but he also
wanted it to taste good. Um,
and we charged a premium price
for it. It is a premium blend. Um,
and we always try to educate.
And Alyssa is an amazing writer and
she writes a lot of blogs and take on.
I started that where we educate our
customers who might be Dunkin donuts or
Folgers or the Starbucks, whatever's
convenient and uh, and we show them the,
you know, this is, this is good
coffee and here's how you can brew it.
Here's Kevin Max,
here's French Press,
here's alternative ways
to enjoy your coffee.
And now a lot of our fans that never, ever
would have gotten into that have like,
you see them like with a whole
station set up and there, you know,
kettles and they're, and they're doing
that. So awesome question. But yeah,
we try to blend the two,
the two worlds.
Thank you. Thank you. Another question.
You alluded to it earlier when
you started selling online,
all of a sudden there are a lot of
orders coming in coming in and you were
falling behind.
I was just wondering if you go a little
bit further into how you scaled during
that, that process in terms of like
vendors, sources and also staff.
How quickly do that scale up and get
you back to where you need it to be?
Yeah, I was, I was very green
back then and I was using,
I think shipstation and all I
was using paypal to, I'd have to,
I'd have to print out
every single order and
basically like I was thrown in the fire,
you know what I mean?
Throwing the fire when,
when good morning America happened,
where we had to produce thousands of
pounds of orders all at once and I didn't
know how to do it.
And that was,
I was operating at a level where I
could probably do maybe 50 pounds a day
comfortably. Um, so yeah.
How quickly did that happen?
Two months. Two months. Um, you know,
we started working with shipstation and
we were both printing owners after that,
you know,
we bought another computer,
so it wasn't just one guy like
printing out the orders. I was,
Kane came on probably three weeks into it,
I think all the time.
They came along a little bit afterwards.
Um,
and there was five of us,
five and at the time, um, when this
was 2013 just guys, just give you some,
some references of time.
Uh, Mike had the idea, 2011,
2012 we started selling
2013 and march of 2013,
good morning America happened. Um,
and you know, as I said before,
like none of us really had jobs.
We didn't know if it was going
to be a sustainable company. Um,
and around June after we got through
that whole thing and we realized that the
sales were still coming and maybe
we're onto something here, um,
we spent the next year making sure that
what had happened would never happen
again. So we had flown up to the roof,
but we didn't have a foundation yet.
So Mike was like,
okay,
let's outsource all this stuff that we
can't or don't want to do in house. Um,
and then let's start slowly after that,
started taking it back in.
So we immediately made lists
and on paper and like, okay,
this is what we're doing now.
This is the process right now.
How do we either get rid of the process?
I have someone else do it or,
or how can we do it more efficiently?
Um, and so one of the things was, okay,
we can outsource to a distribution center.
So we went around and it, and Eric,
who's not here,
um,
went around and just interview
distribution centers and
that was a huge thing.
Now we don't have to actually
package coffee at that time.
I spent anywhere between eight to 12
hours a day, packaging coffee. Um,
and then once we figured out how
to kind of make it sustainable,
we started taking all that stuff back
and we're still taking stuff back, uh,
to be able to do everything under
how, and you know, in house. But, uh,
it was a process.
Scaling is probably one of the tougher
things that we've done. I mean,
Mike was doing our accounting for years.
I'm pretty sure he still
has his hands in it. So I'm,
and I'm the same way with
posting on Instagram like I
shouldn't be doing anymore,
but we're, we're all kind
of doing it. Um, hiring a,
we did use some temp services in the
beginning and we ended up keeping a few of
those people on. Um, but yeah,
that scaling is impossible.
It's not like you can,
you know, look that up on the
Internet. We're so scaling,
same as being able to attract talent.
That's what I was most excited about.
It took a long time cause at
first we would put like, you know,
a Craig's list ad up and like, who, you
know, this person, we're looking for this,
but we don't have money to
pay you. So like, here's a,
a small money. But it's like,
it might be bigger later. And, uh,
I think the most exciting thing for
us right now is where, you know, we,
we've done multimillions of
dollars of sales and, and
we're, we're still, you know,
growing and growing and
growing, um, being able to,
to bring on a Dustin who an absolute beast
and everything he does and, and like,
okay, here's a problem, figure it out.
And he's like, so he builds our, you know,
our entire warehouse and inventory. And
then Jeff, like, you know, so much about,
you know, broadcasts and all
this, your voice, um, Alyssa,
you're a content, you know,
writer, can we, you know, where
you want to come over here?
And went and worked for us and we met able
to do that and we're still doing that.
Super exciting.
Yeah.
It's like working for a small business.
Like I'm somebody that went from working
in a corporation and then it was very
attracted to this,
like,
what is this small business that
seems to be doing really well? Like,
what's going on over here?
How can I get my hands into that?
And I think that as far
as scaling with people,
as people start to see that and as we
have jobs are to opening, people are like,
wait,
how can I get involved in something
that's cool and small and different than
what like, you know, working at the state,
we're in upstate New York, so you know,
that kind of thing.
I don't think we've even touched
on this like that at that point.
Good Morning America. You
said that, you know, it was,
it was a team of five and then that blew
up and obviously scaling up and like I
said,
we're still scaling up.
We have the largest employee
base right now and we're at 25,
2123 and that's the company.
So I mean, you know,
and doing what we do,
it's still how do we,
how do we maintain that base but reach
that ceiling and not, you know, go,
go nuts it.
So
it's a, it's a, it's a
journey. It really is.
I think the coolest thing also is
being able to do what, uh, what we,
what we're passionate about.
Matt when we were having lunch,
he alluded to like the 20% time and
people being able to have time to do
projects they're passionate
about. And, and we, you know,
we're obviously on a much smaller scale,
but we have a lot of things that we,
like for instance, Alissa, you might want
to talk about the grinded out campaign,
our first real marketing campaign
where they had these ideas.
I'll let you talk a little more.
Yeah. So basically what we would like,
we were talking about our fan base.
We have a lot of nurses and firefighters
and things like that that really use
the coffee to get them through the day.
So what we decided to do with kind of
put together a content campaign where we
highlighted those people
because we felt like, you know,
so many companies are like Highland men
who athlete or like highlighting this
super famous person.
But like who we want to champion is the
people that are drinking our coffee.
And that might be the nurse that's in
the hospital or the EMT or all of those
people. So yeah. So basically it
was something where, you know,
the marketing team, me Taya and our
art director Thomas were like, yeah,
wouldn't it be really cool to put together
some videos of these people and blogs
and play lists and all of this kind
of stuff. And Mike was like, do it.
So it's kind of been able to give us the
freedom to just make creative projects
and things like that.
We want to just show up.
We wanted to showcase the greatest tag
line like that you guys came up with is,
is we wanted to showcase how our
coffee lives. Yeah. You know,
and it's not just about whose hands
we can flip coffee into. It's about,
like we said,
you know,
it's like you get up every morning and
you might have a cup of coffee and then
you're going to go do something awesome.
Usually, you know, and it's like, okay,
let's see you do that
awesome thing and why,
how is it and why are you doing that?
And that's kind of where that
whole marketing came to cry it out.
Hashtag Hashtag Rhino everyone
can boy after. Yeah. Yeah.
Like, it's, we want to see everybody's
grind because like you said, it's,
it's how our coffee live.
So cool.
Thank you. It really is, um, uh,
powerful and amazing story of the passion
for a product leading to the creation
of a family, uh, leading to the
creation of a community. Uh,
and it's interesting that the product
itself is sort of secondary to all of that
for you guys. That really it's about
you being able to work together,
follow your passions, and continue
to grow this community out there. Um,
to that respect, please let people know
how they can find all of this. I where,
where do you go to hear the podcast?
How, where can you check out the coffee?
Go to death wish coffee.com. That's
the easiest place. That's the arc.
Our content hub for everything. I mean,
you can find us on Twitter, Instagram,
and Facebook. Obviously I'm
under death wish coffee. Um,
the podcast lives right off our homepage
to go Deathwish coffee.com backslash
outcast, outcast. Uh, what were
the top selling coffee on Amazon?
So if you go over there
and type in coffee,
we should be under the
headline bestseller.
You can buy it there or you can also
get on jet and get it on our website.
We actually
have a, um, we're going to be in
your guys' employee discounts,
I think in the next quarter.
I worked a deal out with a,
I forgot who was the head of that, but
if you do use a discount, Google, um,
you will get 20% off the back of our car
or whatever it was on the website. Um,
so you can share that internally.
It hasn't been announced yet,
but that should be coming. Um,
very soon. It's been announced. No,
you'll be able to find it and just
says that he said he was gonna share it
around the office. I wasn't
a big deal. He just hasn't,
it hasn't been in the newsletter yet,
so I don't think I broke any rules.
We'll see.
Also get off that newsletter and just a,
the podcast location, any Podbean, iTunes,
we're up, we're up there too. So I mean,
yeah, you can pretty much find us anyway.
And like I said, we're getting into
video too, so, you know, youtube, we're,
we're all over that Facebook
live. Excellent. Well,
thank you guys for taking the time to
come and join us and share your amazing
story. Right. Thanks for having
us. Thanks guys. Thank you.